[Music]
ah
what the [__] this guy looking for
what are you looking for logan
i'm just watching patients
this guy is such a [__] character
all right
are we going
what i'm about to stay
move up the table
this guy is absolutely [__]
hello hello one two one two okay okay
what do you what are you about to say
what happened
okay go for it
help
you help
what the [__] is that
what am i about to say may shock you
okay
i was out last night i could tell
i was out late last night and uh
look i don't want to hear it bro like i
know i'm an hour late i don't care let's
go be honest that's fine are you sure no
no i could sorry i was a bit [__] up
this morning myself so it's all good
really yeah that makes me feel good i'm
like that every podcast though like my
russell brown podcast i remember like
for the majority of it just being like
wow
he's really talking fast oh yeah you
know like he talks faster anyway he
talks fast and he says a lot of things
then i was like i really hope people
don't realize
how [__] i am that doesn't feel like a
podcast where you should be toasted it
was the worst one i think i i blocked it
though why'd you get so [__] up dude
it's uh it's a podcaster thing i think
you know what i mean
dude every podcast i go on the host is
getting [__] up yep what's our deal
what the
[__] is wrong with us
we're alcoholics i do think so because
you hear everyone's problems
and it sort of weighs you down a bit and
you start feeling like some sort of
therapist and you're like i just need to
cope i also think it just like loosens
you up a little bit yeah good shot dude
i smoked for the first time online on
andrew schultz podcast
the other day
and i was like nervous how i was going
to be
and i can actually
like handle it i can handle smoking a j
and speaking at length
i think i might i think i might indulge
a little more in the future i think i
think hi logan is like super curious we
could make that happen right now if you
want
not officially
but yeah i i hear you
is it legal here nope
but uh
you know
well yeah i'm still waking up dude i i
we don't want to put you back to sleep
yeah that's the only thing i'm pretty
tired i find i find when i smoke
midday kind of kind of [__] the rest of
my yeah it does and i got a i got a big
day dude yeah i got a big day i'm going
to see book of mormon
i said it
isn't that some [__] play
it's not just some [__] play yeah
okay okay yeah that's the play what was
that what happened last night for though
because you said something happened last
night oh dude i went to the box okay you
want to talk about that i could go for
it i heard mike got two girls back to
his room mike was having threesomes okay
classic well i just like the girls here
in london like i mean tell me
because you've got a you've got an
international palette now you're used to
women you've been all over this shop so
what how did how do london girls differ
from puerto rico america earlier all of
this
tell me i think i think they're they're
just forward
yeah i think so how far would we talk in
like they'll [__] mike malak kind of
forward i mean that's pretty full i mean
like at what point but what how did they
how did they approach you though how do
they approach you um i'm actually spoken
for so i don't i'm not i'm not indulging
but they're approaching in the past
i've been a pr i've been still talking
to you though you know what you know
what i don't think i really get
approached
i'm pretty i'm pretty insulated so when
you're single are you the approacher
like
like i guess the answer would be yeah
but i'm also not i'm not really like
approaching as luck as you feel a bit
like because your position you gotta be
careful
yeah man i'm just so cautious about like
everything
and like if i if i like go for a girl
like you'll know that i'm like i'm like
i'm locked in on you are you i'm like a
one
i just i see what i like and then i'll
just like go
don't lose that from from experience
that's the best way to be because i've
tried it mike's way hey mike plays the
field well yeah mike's the shortstop
mike's the first person likes the
catcher in the picture yeah i did a long
time like that it's not the healthiest
way the healthiest way is just one
person it's a lot less stressful yeah
yeah yeah yeah i'm not like
i like the chase i just like i don't
know man i don't know what kind of women
are we talking like and because
if i'm right in thinking a lot of the
girls i've seen you with in the past
they have a certain sort of status oh oh
you think so i i i don't really see you
with not what i would class as a normal
girl who just happens to work at a
coffee shop like they tend to be in
circles where like that baseball
player's daughter then there was the
actress then there's
you know what i mean like they've got
they've already got a bit of a following
they've already got their blue tick i
see i see i guess yeah historically that
that does make sense
what i've found is uh
uh when when someone is in the same
industry as me or loosely related media
content uh forward-facing
there's a level of relatability there
that the average girl
sometimes
i don't i don't vibe with like like
averages average is such a [__] word for
that well not normal like people in
normal jobs though you do not have a
normal job so therefore someone else
would kind of need to understand that
exactly it is important to yeah it is
also
hyper refreshing when i do find a person
who's not sucked into the social media
world [__] yeah the entertainment
[__] it's also incredibly refreshing
but long term if i'm gonna like be with
someone
it's nice to be able to talk about an
edit on a video or like an opinion on a
picture or or something with his like
like i was at work today and the
director did this and there's like a
back and forth about like uh making a
movie or because you know this person
has been in that world before it's nice
it's nice for me okay yeah so so this
this this latest relationship you're in
does that
has that ticking that box for you
creatively
yeah yeah
what it what what is uh have you
revealed here
no
why not
because i really want to get this right
and you feel like that's [__] it up
last time like yes no i don't feel like
it's [__] it up i just
i i just want to take my time and get it
right because i think
i don't know
i think this one's like special like mmm
really special you love hard though
don't you because i remember the way you
went on with
chloe [__] bennett as you used to
call out
like you do get you do get really like
you say focused in on these yeah well
i'm dude i'm an extremist like that's
just how i am in my life everything i do
it's like that's what i'm doing now i'll
be no bro yeah
i'm to fight who are you fighting flight
mayweather exactly
i want to skip all the [__] in
between like i'm locked in you're going
for the heavyweight title
yeah
yeah so she's a 10. we already know that
um
what is what is the yeah what is what
was the the allure personality wise
um
she's she's [__] hilarious
and smart
and self-aware
she has like she has like every quality
of life like liam payne then not sorry
oh man
no no i don't i don't want to talk too
much about it just just cause like
i don't know i'm i'm
i'm still like
in the water but you know the paparazzi
thing because i i've seen you get popped
when you're starting out with a
relationship is that something you're
very wary of you're like oh yeah last
night you know what we did before we
entered the box because man we actually
like had to press the paparazzi because
we were at this restaurant and she saw
this dude like outside of our window of
the restaurant like creeping with his
phone taking pictures through the window
she's like oh this guy just [__] like
took a picture of that guy right there
so we went out
delete the [__] picture dude he's
like i didn't take a picture i'm like
why creeping through a window he's like
i am paparazzi but i didn't take a
picture
and then uh we realized we were being
like followed
and before we went in so we we go
separate for now like eventually like i
don't
i don't know man just that like
paparazzi photo of you with a girl for
the first time is is is
semi
semi a big deal like i wanna i want the
it goes everywhere doesn't it let's be
yeah man and i want the out to be kind
of under my our control
like are we ready for the world to see
us if the answer is yes then let's
decide what we're going to do about it
how long have you been but last night
listen listen
she went first okay and then uh
me and mike came out holding hands
that's like when you [__] with the cops
when they're following you you're like
come on [__] off we're going for a ride
exactly exactly
yeah
but uh yeah how long have you been
knowing the school day it's a little
over a month now we've been together not
like every day every second of every day
and i've never had a connection
do you ever um
obviously i'm going to ask this do you
worry that it's gone one extreme to
another and you're pushing it too fast
because i feel like sometimes those kind
of situations in my life
they've been a bit like a firework you
know they take off like [__] and then
they explode because it's just
too much too fast too and it doesn't
develop slowly enough so this is what
i'm trying to avoid you know i just i i
don't i just want to get it right
because the extremely special human that
i happen to find
um and i i just
i think there's a lot of meat on this
bone like really like a good a5 wagoo
wow
uh just chew it so i just want to like
just yeah how did you meet roughly if
you could say it without feeling too
yeah it was on a trip
was this on your photography trip it's a
funny story no no
it started there oh really it's like
yeah yeah yeah i'll tell this full story
one day jordy what else you got bro i i
can't i oh sorry no i just like oh man i
don't know i don't know how much
i want to talk about because people run
with this [__] and like i hear you i
hear you that's
i am excited about it i am i'm happy for
you i'm excited about what what i think
i'm i'm building in this relationship i
only worry because
like
yo how old are you now 26 27 27 sorry so
you're in the prime of your life and
you're you're right at your drink you're
you're definitely doing some amazing
things and i get why you'd want a
partner to roll with you along that but
it also
is you know more than anyone it's
[__] hard
and to to what to carry religion through
all that [__] scared her as well
absolutely i'm sure she's she's older
than me she's you're 27 years old you're
still she's older yeah cougar
sorry she's not that much older
she's like six months old and i'm like
no she's like she's 45.
nah she's the oldest woman you've been
with
uh uh in general yeah
probably like probably like 60 65.
[__] off
what's so funny funky
have you ever been with a woman older
than you other than that i go after
grandmas yeah
i've always i've always thought like i
wonder what that'd be like what are you
about to say bro 40s 50s i wonder what
that would be like you know what i mean
just to get a bit of a left giving 40s a
shot no i've been making no [__]
mistake no no you've not given forty
shot i i think it's cause they it's
weird because like
you know like youtuber mothers they like
me whenever i meet the boys mothers they
always look at me and think oh it's all
right like you know but yeah they're all
taken
um
a fan of yours or like or like has a
these older women they i don't know they
look at me a certain way but they're
like yeah but i'm married now so we
can't go down that road i bet you could
jordy yeah yeah i'm going to talk to
them i'll ask mike what he says
liam payne right people have asked me to
ask you about this because like how
could i not this podcast went weirdly
viral um
for
the wrong reasons if you're liam payne
like this guy um not a bad guy you know
he didn't say anything that was
particularly made him a bad person but
he cle he came across
completely
not self-aware now
for you
when you're in the room with him are you
are you aware of that this guy is making
himself look like
a bit of a
douchebag
just checking this out
it's a great question the answer is no
i wasn't aware really i didn't think
anything of even when he said like the
thing about the hands and how you'll use
that lose the use of your hands if you
don't take them off me now
i mean well that's like
male testosterone talk it is but the way
he delivers it looking like him
even even even you were like i think you
were like oh i mean i mean
[Applause]
the guy said he wanted to fight ksi like
he doesn't come across to someone who's
in the room
you know yeah okay
what's wrong with you chucking your hair
out
i just i just look beat right now yeah
but you're doing a liam payne come on
come on i don't get in the room [__]
what do you mean you look beat
i'm just waking up and i'm trying to
answer your questions all good i'm gonna
be bald in like five years so when i
have hair i need to make sure it looks
[__] good are you worried about your
hair genuinely i'm
these are just facts what about hair
replacement and all that [__] would you
do that i'm going to turkey baby
yeah i'm plugging my scalp up i don't
give a [__] you get a butt lift as well
while you're riding i'm getting good
evil i'm getting ash shots i don't care
bro yeah i'm trying to look porcelain
this is why you need to secure this girl
now while you still look awful
now i've been prepping her knock her
down she's you know she we like i like
you i like you too i'm like yo yeah keep
that energy yeah is this why you did the
ball video with ksi yeah i wanted to see
how i was involved turns out not a bad
looking thumb there you go you're all
right this is the thing right people
need to understand that us men who shave
our heads
we're really killing the game because it
ain't it ain't easy to look good with a
shaving head 100 percent 100 what if
your scalp is weirdly there you go my i
got a lemon head brother and three scars
running down this [__] side like i
got scars all over my head one is this
big
chicks dick skulls you'll be fine i love
scars dude i don't have many um tattoos
but
i have so many scars scars are like my
tattoo i want to answer your question
about liam all right um the answer is no
i didn't think anything of the podcast
sure he said some outlandish [__] sure
we were drinking on a podcast my man was
feeling himself trying to stir him
really feeling himself
bro he's feeling himself he's trying to
stir the pot i get it i've done the same
[__] i went on podcast said some dumb
ass [__] i'll say some dumb [__] today
bro and like you know it creates good
media that's all i'm when i'm making the
content online i'm just thinking about
like is this entertaining like someone
gonna see this and walk away with like
like like [__] this guy or like like a
commentary on it anything that like this
sparks a reaction is good so i didn't
give a [__] i was like oh this is i've
done 330 podcasts
i'm so numb to [__] man like i
but he hasn't and for him
this was his chance to speak his truth
and his moment
and
as a boy band member as a singer
you just have to not [__] up and the
kids will love your music and the girls
will sing your songs and he showed that
this idyllic boyfriend that they think
he is is [__] when he's going on
going yeah so uh
i was just like yeah i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna do the band thing anymore i'm
pretty much done i don't need a single
career i've written some of the biggest
songs ever and then oh god ed sheeran
writes as a song go on then i hear you i
hear you but i try to empathize man like
you like no one's lived the life that
that kid has lived
it's it's got to be [__] insane dude
you know and no one knows what kind of
upbringing he has
i mean he's talked about it a little bit
but like truly like to be any one of the
one direction kids
has got to throw you in a [__] loop
dude like
getting that famous and rich that young
can't be healthy right like that famous
unprecedented levels of fame that i'm
not sure we've ever seen before the fan
girls today
still go crazy over these grown-ass men
i've seen you were trending after that
the one directioners were upset with me
yeah cause it's your fault that he
sounded like an idiot i go it's easier
to blame you the winner what have i done
you know but it's it's uh it's it's
guilty by association i'm well aware of
the
siloed
rabid fan groups and their their power
when they get together you piss most of
them off i think yeah
especially the one directioners yeah
like they don't they don't they don't
like jake and i at all but i got so much
love for him
like get the [__] out to zayn yeah and
zayn's like leave me alone no he was
talking [__] he was he was screaming
back behind his door yeah that night
like a tough guy would bro
mate
what was he saying behind the door he's
like he's gonna [__] talk [__] about
me just screaming behind this door and i
tried to go calm him down that night
and he was just yelling i'm like i'm
sure we could fix this like
whatever he's got demons too though the
whole i'm sure they all got demons
except harry styles obviously he's an
angel
yeah
i mean is he though this is the thing
that they were all put in a band because
they weren't strong enough to go solo
from being young and they were able to
lean on each other and be the boyfriends
and those girls have fallen for a hoot
line in singapore and i think what they
got is a dose of reality and it's
probably easier to blame you
than it is to realize this guy isn't
what they thought he was you know it's
something very interesting about being a
social media personality
especially the type that i am where my
life is kind of just my content right
i'm just living and sharing
um
big blessing that you either like me or
don't like me for exactly who the [__] i
am no surprise here right
with artists
actors
um entertainers often they're in
character their art is the thing you
like and know them for so they have to
hide the real them you don't know who
this [__] person is that's why they
don't do podcasts a lot of these people
100 you don't know who these people are
you like their music you like their song
then you meet them in real life you find
out their [__] piece of [__] happens
time and time and time again they say
don't meet your heroes some of them are
awesome others you meet and you're just
disappointed
being being being a likable a human is
hard you ever had a hero disappointing
you like someone who you thought was
going to be cool can you say who that
was uh there are
the rock really yeah why was it
disappointing
because i remember me and you talking
about the rock actually on this part on
the podcast how you used to idolize the
fact that he'd conquered so many
different forms of entertainment and
that you wanted to sort of replicate
that in your own style
it's a big hero i've never i've never
told this story well fantastic
i mean you've already said the rock meet
come on and justify all right i'll give
you some i'll give you some alpha
[__] man
all right i love you jordy
i loved dwayne the rock johnson
he's the best who doesn't okay he's so
likable
works hard
motivational is his energy is contagious
he's always on jets
he's always hungry
um
yeah and he and he in a weird way
there's no blueprint to the [__] that
i'm doing but in a weird way he made he
made a blueprint for something that
wasn't
a a career path that did not exist yet
you could do it yeah and in the same way
i kind of want to do something like that
it'll look vastly different
but you know
in parallel i believe i'll build a
multi-faceted career in the same way
dwayne the rock johnson has
anyway
you know they look at where the rock is
now when the rock was your age he didn't
have two pennies to rub together and he
was a nobody so you're already way ahead
of where he was he was a struggling
wrestler i think he flunked out of the
nfl didn't make it and again if you're
laughing at that like you're a [__]
loser i was like i've proven time and
time again that nothing's impossible and
i'm gonna continue doing that and
everyone should believe that and go do
the [__] you want to do in life
okay
we made a couple of videos together me
and duane back in the day when i was
making instagram vine sketches and uh
great guy in real life i was scared to
meet him because i was like is he gonna
be one of those people who i meet and i
i i fall out of love with my idea of him
and no sweetheart give me the time of
day have a nice conversation it was
awesome made made like made like
three three or four videos on separate
occasions that all went like crazy viral
like i would i would consider him like
not maybe not like a
a friend
but definitely like an acquaintance like
very friendly with each other like
me and dwayne what's up
um
i don't know if i can tell the story i
know you really don't uh want to say it
because how much you like him or
whatever but come on logan
tell the truth
[Applause]
um this was like this was like this this
is one of the saddest uh moments of my
life
what i'm about to say
after
japan happened
um
obviously
found myself
in a hole rightfully so that i had never
been in before
extremely
low mentally
and i got a call from my publicist
who
also
repped dwayne
the rock johnson
and
she's like hey dwayne has asked that you
remove every
uh picture and video that you've you've
done with him
um
and and maybe maybe in the future you
know the relationship can be reconciled
but for for now
he basically wants nothing to do with
you
which i also understood
i get it
you know i made a
grotesque error
and and and he has had things happen in
his life where
like a lot of people that that that
incident affected him in
vastly different in a personal way
personally i get you
so i understood it and that was the
other part
i i i
was like [__]
[__] i sleep in the bed you make right
but i just wish i would have gotten like
a call
or a text or something
because like i thought we had a
like a healthy
relationship an open line of
communication and i
was so sad
that my hero wanted nothing to do with
me
that sucks bro
and i was sad because
i understood it
i really [__] up
but it was the lack of a
a one to one
just something man like or even attack
something anything yeah anything yeah
because you were good enough when you
you were the hot kid on vine and he he
was benefiting off that relationship of
being seen to be
an older guy
because he's in with the cool kids yeah
by the way he didn't need me by not
saying i needed you but you it's it's
the same reason jay-z
works with any hot rapper who's coming
up is to to maintain hit jay-z and the
rock isn't stupid you know he's clearly
done things so he was benefiting in a
way you know what i mean
um and and and
again that's i i totally got where he
was coming from you know
i was just i was so disappointed like
in myself like a real disappointment in
myself yeah and so
i i
i vowed to get better about to change
whatever time passed we i start doing
well
and uh
i just
i don't know i
i just wanted to
be able to build the relationship with
with with dwayne that
didn't end up happening and that was
that was good
reach out again huh did you reach out
again
i did not reach out he did
he did
about
maybe like five months ago
nah three months ago how did he reach
out
like nothing ever happened what like a
text message or uh uh instagram dm okay
what was it just like hey you know that
you know that video where the monkey
took my prime yeah he thought it was
funny
and uh and he didn't acknowledge that
there was ever any
disconnect there
and what did you do did you reply
hey fair play like
that's a hero and you're you're
basically saying
if i wasn't good enough in my dark times
am i good enough now for you okay well
no thank you then
and that was the frame of mind was it
yeah yeah makes sense
because everyone wants you on the come
up
it's interesting how that works
do you think you might reply
in time
i think i'm a scumbag for outing this
story not really i think what you're
you're not saying he's a bad person for
what he did particularly he's not he's
no dude he's he's [__] awesome dwayne
the rock johnson is awesome i love him
but i was also just like
he doesn't he doesn't look at you as a
as a fan of his though
what he was looking at that was like
i guess he's he's judging you and
treating you
not as his number one fan or someone who
admires him so much he's he's going
you're a big boy now and i'm going to
treat you like a big boy i guess but i
get you considering how much the
relationship was there
to work with him several times
a message or anything would be like look
bro i know you're going through a [__]
time right now but i'm afraid i'm going
to have to do this because i did have i
did have heroes of mine do that
they did it we'll reconnect later on
when you're following me personally yeah
yeah hey bro i'm sure you understand i
can't i can't have anything to do with
you right now yeah yeah right yeah like
which yeah yeah and i said i go dude i
[__] feel you what do you like it's
all gone anything we've ever done like
it's all
you know um and and you know he's busy
he don't gotta you know owe me [__] he
don't owe me [__] i want to make it very
clear but like damn i'd be lying if i
said i wasn't it hurt i'm sorry this
took this was so
long and drawn out to like explain not
really but like i've never told that
story and i i never meant to
but you asked and and
so
look
what you haven't you haven't houred them
as some sort of [__] serial killer
though don't beat yourself up like you
know
no not that just like you know how
me telling these stories does it damage
does it damage
what there's a damage if anything i
think it's more likely to
make
him understand how you felt about it and
then i've wanted to have a conversation
with him about it but like i don't know
why didn't you reply like aside from
what we said before though because i
didn't know what to say
uh i'm still stuck on the you have the
cold turkey i'm still stuck on the hey
bro hey kid
i know we were cool i don't want [__]
anything to do with you delete
everything that i'm in
connected to you uh-huh i'm i'm still
stuck on that because so four years
later when it's like uh
hey dude
quote-unquote always been supporting me
supporting you from afar key word afar
like
i don't know what to say dude like i
can't i cannot forget about me
what
is deleting everything always supporting
me is yeah
i said to my boys they go you have
keyword afar yeah it's like
and i also get it i get it but like i
can't do i can't forget about the i'm
still stuck here and then
and it hurt and he he he
probably didn't think twice about it you
know or
definitely or i've considered this
i've considered this
uh
my publishers just made all of it up in
which case i'm a [__] [__]
okay because they're supposed to protect
him too
the only thing is they also rep kevin
hart
and i had made videos with kevin
like when i say rep it's like one to one
that is
she is my publisher as well
and kevin and i and kevin didn't have me
remove the video oh
kevin hart
same [__] had a bunch of viral videos oh
yeah you know what
but kevin hart's a different breed
doesn't he to the rock in that regard
he's been canceled he's been through a
lot of things he's a comedian i agree
whereas the rock is cleaner than clean
only the only thing the rock did
ever that like
polarized was when he said he was voting
for biden
um when he said he was voting blue
he's an interesting character isn't he
he's yeah he's great uh what was it like
going into the wrestling then
incredible yeah incredible that's it
before we like do a full pivot that's
another reason why i'm like i'm sitting
here like does it damage you know like
with like he's he's involved in the
wrestling world dwayne and i like we're
going to cross [__] patterns if
anything there's an angle there now that
put you in a ring together if they knew
what they were doing they [__] should
by the way
that'd be crazy well they do know what
they're doing because i'm on board now
um
i i well
i think you have major potential in the
wrestling world you are the most natural
wrestler thanks they could have found
thanks man that that first match because
i've been watching wrestling we're
actually i'm doing a podcast today later
the day with uh sean michaels the
heartbreak kid um so i'm a you know an
old-school steve austin wrestling fan
all of that you were so good thanks dude
you were amazing thanks man the whole
even the whole wrestling world you know
he wanted you to be back i know all of
those kids who were praying they were
like [__] me this is like this kid's
actually great thanks man yeah thanks
when i get that reaction when i'm like
when i see like oh [__] he's good no i i
was i was watching the twitter like i
was like i was having a little look at
the the when you were trending yeah to
say the general reaction and it was i've
got we've got to say that is the best
debut we've especially at wrestlemania
thanks man
mental mode i only trained two days dude
bro that is [__] insane i'm i'm just
scratching the surface with what i can
do in that room that is mendel
i'm so excited you're doing the frog
splash you're doing the [__] just
wait just wait i'll give it all i'll
give it everything so you're saying
you're on board now you've signed a deal
with them which i think is great
well i don't know i i i'm considering it
i think that i think that's a good move
for you because
the thing about wrestling is a it's not
like boxing in the sense that you can do
it regularly get that money but also
you're going to tap into an audience
that will only make you 10 times bigger
those wrestling fans are so [__]
loyal the rock's career now has been
built off of that however
yeah yeah those fans are die hard and
they followed him like right into the
movies and that enabled them to to get
and i was watching thinking why is stone
cold steve austin wrestling this owens
fella yeah stone cold steve austin
should be wrestling logan paul you get
what what you did with mayweather they
should have done that he's he's fought
the greatest boxer now he's wrestling
the greatest wrestler some [__] like
that that would have made the most sense
that makes the most sense to me now i
think they wanted to see what i could do
right i got that that was that was my
case study yeah and and my number one
objective was to deliver right it's up
to the fans dude
i don't give a [__]
what i want to do if the fans don't like
me
or do like me like
it that's going to be the determinant
whether i come back or not turns out
might have a little meat on that bro bro
so i i don't watch this when you look at
the camera and you go watch this
and you do the three suplexes as an
old-school wrestling fan i was like
[__] look at him go
like
don't get me wrong you're a in my
opinion
percy your boxing performance against
floyd really showed how good you are at
that
but
this wrestling thing you could do that
for will you look at brock lesnar he's
doing that now in his 40s he's still
making 10 million a year off of this
stuff like 12. whatever yeah there's so
much potential for you and longevity
yeah sustainability you're the new you
could be the new hulk hogan type figure
like you know blonde head blue eyed kid
dodgy hairline no
um i just wanna you know where it gets
uh
difficult
is
again i got famous for being me um i
don't have a character
you know do we really know who hulk
hogan is um
you know hulk hogan yeah you know
something brother yeah you know so like
i can't be overly performative in my
[Applause]
approach because i'm not playing
a character i don't know how and i don't
know how many wrestlers are like playing
a character when they when they hop in
that ring versus
are just being themselves the bad one
myself the best ones from what my
experience is is it's closer themselves
but you turn the volume right up that's
what storm called steve austin said it's
me but on a 10. you know like is he a
redneck who loves drinking beer yes but
it's that with all the volume tonight
the same with the rock we've seen
that charisma so what so i'll just be a
[__] [__] and turn the volume up
but no but you're you're but this is the
thing is when you said like uh i've got
pool toys bigger than you bucko like
that was that was you that was hilarious
and that's what you can bring to the
table yeah athleticism
to me you could be like
you know that i don't know if you
remember like the eddie guerreros and
the kurt angles like they weren't the
most biggest guys but they were [__]
athletic and they
kept you interested the whole time
but this is the problem noise
you've got so much going on so how do
you balance boxing wrestling nfts all of
this business that you're building so
hard yeah it's so hard uh
i don't know living in puerto rico helps
really because i can just stay focused
yeah la new york is so much noise and
you don't you don't realize how much
noises are is in that big city until you
leave and and you you gain 50 percent of
your energy back because it's been
sucked out of you by the people around
you mm-hmm um
but yeah i in the wrestling sense how
far do you want to take that
you know this is a
[Applause]
question i've been asking myself because
to to to commit to wrestling like that
is a little bit of a brand shift which
is a big deal
um
i do combat obviously
i do podcasts
i build businesses
um and now i'd also brand myself as an
artist with this photography project
that i did and so
you know
all of those things is already a bit of
a
hard
pill to swallow because like
you know i just do a lot and so then you
add a wrestler on that it gives a
different feel to to
me like the brand that is logan paul and
i hate talking about it in like
you know liam payne yeah yeah but like
it's just the reality of the situation
like there's there's a brand that's been
built that i
happens
to be an amplification of myself
and i just wanted to make sense
i can you can can you be a wwe superstar
and a professional nfd photographer
me probably yeah i would say something
yeah no um but not
with people without people being like
wait what no i think i think it's about
the time i don't think anyone's going to
stop you it's more there's only only so
many hours in a [__] day
and
like your body can that cannot withstand
wa wrestling boxing and everything else
i'll tell you what we're gonna find out
i guess we are bro we're gonna find out
i'm not i'm not concerned about my body
i'm worried about public sentiment
that's what i'm worried about it's hard
to i'm interested in so many things
it's hard to keep people
attention on those yeah yeah like like
even
like i have i have fans but
for what the answer is always different
are you worried about not focusing on
one thing because if we look at the most
successful people
there's a sustained period of time where
they sort of
they do that one thing like joe rogers
exactly exactly the rock is a movie star
exactly so you're kind of spreading
yourself thin yeah and that may dilute
down the product of what you're putting
out 100
100 percent
i do have the cushion that is prime
hydration
uh
i i'm serious i'm serious no i know you
will the only respect thanks bro the
only the only reason
the only reason i would worry about
spreading myself too thin is is not
making a really big impact in one of the
things okay
although that's gonna always be the goal
in everything that i do
prime is an amazing
backbone
because of
the success we've achieved i'll just so
i'm prime i'm assuming that was your
idea because of the way it's been the
story's been told did it started with
you and then you took it to jj is that
right
here's what happened
um the ceo kind of chases down me down
for a while he's like i want to make a
beverage with you
jeff kind of
we ignored
you know the company for maybe like six
seven months and then my manager um
finally took the phone call and the guy
was sharp and i think the ceo pitched
jj to me
and then and then i liked the idea
i said i actually i actually could see
how me and him coming together would
make a splash
so what are we making he goes i don't
know like what do we want to do
you know like what's our product
that's our hydration
we could fill that niche we could
probably do a bit of a disruptive
takeover um i want it to be bold i want
it to be in your face
bright colors
uh amazing product
what about prime does that work
and so i went to jj and i pitched him
the idea i was like hey dude like and
this is gonna [__] sound crazy
because i know like i know what kind of
like where we stand
but do you want to make a business
together
and he liked the idea
and his manager and his team liked the
idea
and it [__] worked
it worked what's your
estimated if if you sell
what do you think you sell that for
because i remember 50 cent selling
vitamin water and making 400 million off
of his share of it yep
my number is five billion
for prime
which i think we'll we'll we'll hit in
three years
i i see you being a billionaire there's
no doubt in my mind that you're going to
hit that thanks bro you know what i want
to be i want to be the anti-billionaire
oh yeah i want to be the
i want to be the [__]
the billionaire who doesn't act like a
billionaire at all
like i want to i want to wear like
shorts
like no shoes like you are right now
like you walked in here without shoes on
i said i'd literally go that guy's
[__] cool
like i want to i want to just i want to
do [__] that billionaires don't do
because i'm young and [__] crazy
and also i document my life yeah my life
is my media
so like what does that look like what is
it like inside a real [__]
billionaire's life
you know
what is that journey come with me let's
go find out let's go [__] let's give
money back let's spend money on crazy
[__] let's have our money make money
let's build more companies
what does it look like
but
in regards to money obviously you've
already got a lot of money and you're
chasing that
like generational wealth right now and
you're but you're setting yourself up to
be
just insanely wealthy but when you've
got all that what is the point of it for
you
aside from having fun aside from
documenting yeah because that's
obviously partly an ego trip yeah so
what is the
what is the outer of that yeah
it's it's a it's a great question yeah
cause like i don't know bro i never i
never chased money it just money is a is
a
fruitful byproduct of the thing that i
love to do exactly yeah you know and i
happen to be smart enough to amplify
it exponentially um
but what's the goal i mean bro uh
one word answer money
is a scoreboard
it's a game to me
where do you rank on that scoreboard
you know how many how many billionaires
how many self-made billionaires are
there
under 30.
american self-made billionaires under
30. not many i would i would but it
can't be [__] more than
10. yeah
exactly you know that's cool that's cool
to me how many kids will that inspire i
mean sure like inspire to do what make
money for whatever but like i don't know
no there's nothing wrong with making
money i just mean what
is there anything that you would do with
that money that you would feel would be
a lasting legacy as opposed to
documenting getting the money you know
what i'm saying oh yeah i kind of like
uh beast's
philosophy
he wants to die with zero dollars to his
name which i which i also kind of like
i think i think i think i'll probably
end up giving 90 of it away or back or
like i just won't like i i you you
mention generational wealth i don't give
a [__] about generational wealth i do my
kids can if i raise my kids correctly
they'll create their version of
generational wealth they're not going to
need my money in fact they're not what
if that computer is
a little sort of waster who just wants
to use daddy's money to play playstation
no shot
no shot no i'm not my kid's friend i'm
not i'm not going to buy him the [__] he
wants to buy i'm my kid's father yeah
like i i'm gonna i'm gonna raise him
you're gonna give them the greg
treatment then a a a a healthy version
of the grape
i cannot give them the great treat
and
nah but dude you know you got to be a
dad you got to be a [__] dad and like
i'm going to raise my kids
with really important strong values
where they're going to be able to create
their own [__] and not need to use my
money
dana white made an offer or
accepted that you would be
welcome in the ufc in a roundabout way
how much thought are you putting into
that as well because to me that is
something that you've always talked
about i'm taking out patty the baddie
dude
interesting i'm taking him out because
he's sat in that chair we know paddy
patty has sat here before right there
yeah [__] this chair
it's like
so he he gets up to over 200 pounds in
his offseason recently oh i know this
guy loves the food yeah and when when i
met him i was a lot of people have
commented on the size difference between
you two and there is a height different
some of me wrong but i'm surprised at
how big he can get yeah for a for a
lightweight he is big real big so
that would make massive money
are you training for it though because
like this is something you need like
this guy is a savage you know what i
mean is he
100 yeah sure he said i'm sure yeah like
what makes you think that well uh it's a
lot of wins caught a couple guys yeah
bro i have a lot of wins yeah
um
i don't think you have
any wins in combat sport yeah have you i
guess you're right yeah
but i don't have a single one i know
you've got the potential to be a bad
[__] in the ufc though like i
this is something you could actually do
it's just i don't know with every you
you can't part-time
mma can you watch me
crazy like a fox on you i'm going to get
them yeah
do you think they might make that kick
to the jaw brother
[Music]
bang zoom have you spoke to dinner since
that conversation
i think i texted him about something
no you know what maybe not no
we gotta we gotta [__] over day in a
little bit
i'm not gonna lie we didn't [__] him
over we didn't [__] him over but like i
did him a little dirty and he might be
upset with me i don't know if he's upset
how come
okay you know
did you see the bald video with me and
ksi yep you know this scene where jg and
i were sitting down and we're like
hey man you have any advice for us like
what's the number one key to success
and we cut to dana white and he's like i
think you guys got it figured out and
the joke was like we're trying to be
successful so we shaved our head because
all bald people are successful look at
you
right
and the joke was like dana's bald and
like he's successful and so he's like i
think you guys got it figured out
well we we shot that separately so they
didn't know what context it was going to
be used in i was just like hey do you
want to like be in this sketch with case
i and i
and then we just like we were poking fun
fun
of him being bald
surely that's fine but it was used in
like a prime commercial that's the only
thing oh i mean it's like
essentially that video is a commercial
right it's like an entertaining one but
at the end of the day it's [__]
bad for our drink yeah and so like i
don't know maybe he's upset about it
maybe he doesn't give a [__] maybe i'm
overthinking which i often do
[__]
what do i do okay
let's calm down okay oh okay kick it in
okay okay
okay um energies all right you you've
went balls do you stop
oh you don't want to talk about them no
one does
um
bad
dude it's just like what the [__] is
going on i did i did what's going on
you put so much effort so this is the
thing is the last time you were here you
were going around the world taking all
these photos and you were like i've got
this idea it's going to be [__] sick
and that was potentially the most
excited i've ever seen you about
anything and obviously just before you
do your big drop
everything crashes crashes crashes
nine months of the hardest most
passionate work of my life about about
to drop a project that i could
but i believe could be the beginning of
my magnum opus my life's work
and the market crashes
it's very wool for wall street in the
movie yeah yeah but guess what
our [__] is strong
originals is strong it's it's still
doing well but but
is there an issue there with the value
of what you initially intended to get
and like so say for example
there was a guy who bought a spot on the
podcast yep three hundred thousand
dollars that polaroid sold okay so the
original the the value of what he bought
was three hundred thousand now so but
now what you've got is not worth three
hundred thousand does it let's see let's
see he bought it for a hundred and
sixty-five eth eth is at 1200 right now
it's probably worth about
190 or 200 000. yes so essentially he
in cash he'd pay much much less but an
eth is not measured in
usd that's just the metric by which we
look at it
so um yeah i i don't give i don't give a
[__] i i i know exactly what i'm
building and and
people are catching on
and this is just the beginning like
originals is a
a uh tech
uh organization
disguised as an art project
art is the v
the medium
that i am telling the stories of my art
on is the blockchain which is why
nft land works for me as an artist right
i'm not like a painter i'm a capturer
i'm a documentary i'm a storyteller i
tell the stories i capture the art
it goes on the blockchain it's called
originals because there's an original
piece tied to it that the holders will
get eventually the actual polaroid that
is ex it's what you see is what you get
they're unaltered um
and then
the the the holders join what's called a
dao a decentralized autonomous
organization so half of the money goes
into this dow and then the holders are
going to decide what to do with it right
so there's so many smart ways to
strategically allocate money using the
brains of smart people so it's it's it's
it's the beginning of uh
uh i think the future of community
is what i think it is that's what i'm
building so while i launch at the
shittiest time ever
um
it doesn't really matter it doesn't it's
it's almost irrelevant actually and also
when i think when i think
when when we
my community make it out of this woods
out of these woods as the only
the only project
that is still thriving
i
think it'll be notable it's thriving
partially because of you the one you're
not allowing it to do what the rest of
them have done because you have a bit of
a superpower in that you are a promoting
expert and
you're the creator and people are
invested in you
more so than the concept sure sure
so uh you chose the right jockey i've
had projects that didn't turn out the
way that i wanted them to that
definitely were not the intention of
them
gary said this on my podcast a big
mistake investors make sometimes and the
ones that one that he sees a lot is
he'll have young entrepreneurs
uh
pitch you know him and and send their
decks around and
an investor will uh invest in an
entrepreneur's first project maybe it
doesn't work out right it's his first
project and then he comes up with a
second one an investor will invest in
his second project fails again right
then he comes with a third
and the investor goes dog you've lost me
money twice like i've bet on you twice
now and i'm actually not gonna i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna believe in in your
stuff this time because we've been
through this before
number three takes off that's exactly
what happened with jim shock by the way
really shout out to ben francis really
like he tried something fail try
something fail try something works yeah
but it didn't work quite as well and
then the third thing i think it was what
was what took off exactly so oftentimes
people will lose hope
because of failed projects but like if
you're a real builder and a real winner
you keep building you're going to keep
building and something's going to work
originals will be the first thing that i
do that like
check
that worked
is the issue with crypt although that
you because you've been involved in
multiple things before
it has that impacted your reputation in
the 100
100 because i see people giving multiple
explanations for why these haven't
worked and you know there's accusations
out there
um
how does it make you feel when people
are doing these takedown videos about
your nft projects previously uh it's
it's sad because
of what i just said
there's so much [__] going on behind the
scenes like you like do you just feel
like i don't owe you an explanation
because you don't know the more i talk
about something the more attention it
will get okay yeah and i will
explain everything one day with my
manager who's like
in charge now
now again retroactively working to make
that make these projects right and the
[__] takes time bro it just [__]
takes time development takes time yeah
to make a project that works like i'm
i'm sorry yo we don't have your [__]
answers today you're not going to 100x
overnight everyone's to get rich quick
and crypto it takes time to build yeah
it takes time originals would be a
decade-long project yeah i did realize
that because i got in on something that
i think you were in on aviv
yeah you called me and uh
same thing like that's plummeted you
know
and they've got disney they've got doug
i'm not the [__] bad guy here yeah
yeah there's some actual [__] out
there yeah and it's not me like i'm here
to build to be an honest builder and i
know what i'm building i know i have a
good heart i know where my head's at i
know i [__] up a lot but i've learned
from all of it
i'm dangerous dude but i'm i'm liam
painting right now bro
i don't give a [__] bro i started one
direction
well i did
y'all don't believe me yo louie was in
the back he was organizing it y'all
don't believe me
i pitched one direction to simon cowell
that's it
clip it what about take it away blogs
the the problem though with nft
nfts is
is rich people fun right and the problem
you buy the [__] monkey
[Applause]
a monkey
there's rich people fun to win it how is
that a [__] how does that work what
happened here still owning all these
pictures that were worth hundreds of
thousands
hell yeah i do yeah some of them are
sick
and some of them i really believe in the
women ones and that you look like i love
the woman one world of women you know
why though you know why though
because i really like what they
represent that's why i love that project
it's my proudest project i'm behind and
what i'm realizing actually in this
crypto crash being someone who is still
actively releasing a crypto project at
the worst time ever
it is it is and this is this is the
mistake
that i made the first two times this is
what i'm realizing now
it is about community
community
that's the beautiful thing about some of
these projects
the community of people that you build
around a unified belief in something
putting smart minds together
is beautiful
it's actually amazing man i i mentioned
i'm building this dao the people in it
we we have like a chat
it's incredible they're all so excited
about the same thing i'm excited about
what can you do with that that's
exciting the world of women thing it
represents inclusion represents women in
crypto and blockchain
art
community like i just love it to me
though as much as it is about art and
creation
it's about money
and overall with all the money that
you've put in and all the money you've
taken out where do you think you're
sitting right now in terms of
profit losses
i'm probably even really because the
market right now do you think you're
about you're one of the few who's even
though
right now yeah for sure for sure
if you bought eth in the past like two
and a half years you're down
fact
if you are a human being who bought
ethereum the past two and a half years
you're down most everyone is
um and so yeah my
i happen to have some big ass wins
but now saved you hasn't it that's saved
you saved me yeah yeah for sure i'm but
i'm even now man i
i've had some big losses you know where
such is life dude
let's talk boxing all right let's
[__] do it floyd mayweather
said he was going to pay you
paid your upfront money didn't give you
your pay-per-view share
oh it's dumb as hell how much do you
think this guy owes you because when i
when i was in here i remember you
talking about
the millions that you thought you were
going to get yeah from that yeah
yeah how much do you think he owes you
my guess is between two and five two and
five mil
conservatively and he's saying recently
you've been paid this [__]
i've been i'm sure i've been paid yeah
not in full yeah technically yeah you're
right dude what about the rest of my
money like uh we'll we'll
this will be settled this will be
settled and and like i'm young dude i
got time do you have [__] time to
troll to
uh
settle a civil war this is down to his
struggles though financially because
there's there's a lot of talk about how
much he's worth but yeah but the actions
he has of a man in his late for coming
up mid to late 40s now still fighting
with these random people in random
places yeah
for five million here 10 million there
yeah he's just a big spender he can't
spend like that you know this guy has a
lot of chains
so many change bro that's yo chains
that's a depreciating asset
get yourself something that'll hold
value here go buy some real estate
brother
buy an original we'd love to have you in
the dow what invest in prime huh
do something smart with your money floyd
he went on a
it was a press conference or something
the other day
and uh he he had the audacity to tell
the media that i asked for a rematch
let me just set the record straight
why the [__] would i ask for a rematch
for someone who doesn't pay you for the
fight
if i haven't been paid for the first one
why on god's green earth would i ask you
for a second fight knowing damn well i'm
probably also not going to get paid the
money that i was owed for my work you
dumb ass
second off
they asked us for a rematch i bet they
did
he was supposed to fight on top of the
burj al arab in dubai was that
the seven star hotel he was going to
fight that youtube kid right yep yep uh
uh
with the with the
helipad up right would have been amazing
got called a month and a half before
because some [__] happened with his
opponent
hey would you want to fight floyd in a
month and a half
someone from his team or someone who at
least thought they could get the deal
done enough to make give us a a
confidential phone call
i go what
bro pay me for the first [__] fight
so how's he managed to get away with
this then i'm assuming the money was
transferred to him initially because it
was his promotional company yeah and
then the idea was he would pay you out
yeah okay yeah because also
before you fight floyd mayweather
i'll do whatever you [__] need yeah
tell me where to sign
now i'm like oh [__]
maybe we shouldn't had some sort of
escrow account or like an arbitrator or
like someone running the deal
instead of mayweather promotions
i've said too much on this podcast
[Laughter]
i've said why they [__] do you know
what i'm like
i'll try it out with you who do you want
to fight next because that's the problem
now you've went to floyd [__]
mayweather and you by the way i think
that was the best performance of any
youtube boxer when you fought floyd
thanks in terms of
boxing skill let me tell you something
who do you fight now wait
before i answer that question i want to
tell you something go for it
no let me ask you let me ask you do you
think any any uh internet boxer youtube
boxer
would have survived against floyd
i'd say no the answer is no no the
answer is absolutely [__] not not
even my own brother yeah the only thing
with jake is there's a punch there that
could you know that could end it at any
time you hit him but you're not gonna
hit him you're not hitting them not not
not with the way
that would have gone no yeah i'm i'm
fast
i was able to hit him barely
a couple times so you were able to hit
him because of your style and that's the
point is because you have like reflex
space and you're on the back foot and he
was coming in jake jake is an aggressor
and that's what floyd loves so you
counter punch him and that's why you got
him a couple of times you know what i
mean that's the way to get flight really
as much as you
yeah no no but you can't put the power
on those kind of punches because you're
throwing them while moving back and you
know yep and by the way i'd love to put
this to the test like let's put the best
we got against against floyd and see
what happens i could be wrong i could
[__] i maybe i suck maybe maybe jake
paul does not know but i just ksi does i
think it's the style your style
is quite defensive and
and good on the on the move
and i just think that with a lot of
other people he would have gassed them
out because you're a great athlete you
were able to keep going you got your
second win
i wish it was a ten round oh man i think
you were coming away
i i don't think people give you anywhere
near enough credit even for surviving
that it was amazing can i ask you
something go for it be honest with me
how many rounds do you think i won
against floyd
well off the top of my head
i remember thinking about three
off the top of my head
andrew schultz tell your [__] boy
that i won three
what were they three rounds doug
he his boy i said i won three as well
yeah yeah i said three yeah i think
that's like objective like you know
whatever you say
his boy said he his voice said i want
one no i go i see your dog you tripping
like what the [__]
he didn't want to give it to me anyways
sorry doc but did you see those persons
mayweather funds
they they have these like i remember
when connor fought floyd i kind of won
about three as well all right let's say
roughly yeah now
was that a what was that a 12-round yeah
well i think it was a 12-round it ended
in the 10th but but a lot of mayweather
fans like to go oh well it's because he
let him it's like well whatever it
doesn't matter whether you let him or
not what whatever you've got to say
it doesn't matter women [__]
youtubers winning rounds is winning
rounds but you the [__] do you want
you guys this is
like a box this was your second like pro
fight yeah you know what i mean ever it
was like you had like an mma career like
conor mcgregor did you literally were
like okay let's see if i can do this
boxing against the greatest of all time
or one of them yeah you know so
who would you want to fight now though
is it because it's hard because you
thought
they led like one of the goats now where
do you go
back to youtube austin mcbroom one of
those guys no
i'm gonna piece up dylan dennis
really yeah
i would love that i've gotta be honest
everyone would love it yes that dude is
the [__] gum that sticks to the
bottom of your shoe
that dude sucks
i'm gonna shut his ass up
do you think he'll get in the ring
though with you because he's one of
those guys who he loves talking but he
never he's he's that kid who runs away
isn't he he i know he's great at jiu
jitsu but yeah come on he'll talk about
getting in the room yeah he'll he'll
talk about it make no mistake he'll do
his little trolling online it'll get a
little attention
but the moment you sign that contract
and especially the moment that you're in
the ring across from me the story's
gonna change a little bit it's much
scarier than you think and you're gonna
get hit with a big [__] shot where
you're gonna wake up and realize that oh
[__]
i've made a grave error and especially
jordy i'm coming off fighting the
greatest boxer ever potentially
do you know what that does to someone's
confidence in a sport
the next person that i get in the ring
with will not walk out of that ring
conscious fact i believe you
like i i i and i've been humbled before
like i've lost in boxing like and and i
know what it tastes like and i'm not
[__] going back and then i fought
floyd i'm angry dude i'm fired the [__]
up and like how's the hand with the
enemy fantastic it's a [__] mallet
now i got a 40 millimeter titanium screw
in my hand and the knuckle
is flattened okay yeah so the right hand
boom
mallet dude i'm fired up jordy and
my brother is murdering it yeah
my little brother is killing it yeah
talk about motivation yeah talk about
inspiration he's my he's giving so much
respect to our family name now i gotta i
gotta
match you know i gotta be on par you've
seen dylan have you seen any of his
fights in his boxing and his i've see
i've seen uh i've seen he's i think he's
fight twice yeah in bellator he didn't
look great on the feet if we're being
honest he didn't i think you've you've
got him quite comfortably i think you're
smashing
[Music]
yeah
bro it's it i won't be in there for more
than four rounds i i'd be surprised if
it was two if i'm honest i think you'll
i'm gonna
i'm gonna uh i'm gonna feel him out a
little bit and then yeah it'll it won't
be he just doesn't have that snap to it
when i watched him hit the bag once and
i watched him spa he released a little
bit of footage i just thought there's
just nothing there there's no power at
all did you see him get choked out by
the bouncer yeah
michael bisping told us he was a
chocolatier actually a chocolate he was
a chocolate maker who was part-time
bouncer he wasn't even full-time bouncer
he didn't even know jiu-jitsu the guy's
a chocolatier he makes chocolates how
does dylan dennis a jujitsu god get
choked out by a chocolatier
what happened i don't know you must have
offered him some
thornton's chocolate so weird dude
oh that's so weird i can't wait for the
day where are you going to make this
fight though is this actually going to
be made we'll attempt we will attempt i
will give him an offer okay and he'll
probably be like this is not what i'm
worth yeah blah blah blah yeah it is
bucko you you you're not even worth that
i mean because i'm gonna i will find
someone i will [__] find someone that
will sign on the con on the dotted line
and i will make someone extremely
[__] rich and famous for the rest of
their life sure it's going to be
incredibly embarrassing you'll get tyron
woodley
and like you're going to have to
you're going to be a medium there's like
there's some good up and coming uh
boxers as well coming into youtube
though like there was that fears kid who
looked really good sure um there's kenny
who looks pretty good out of um beta
squad and also face sensei people like
that
a couple things there's levels to this
[__]
you want a real fighter as in dylan
dennis is four in america i i just i
just i there's a couple things one you
have to
be able to sell a fight and then b i
just don't think those fights would be
on par okay i don't think that people
would believe that it could be a good
fight i think the dillon dynasting the
fact that he was conor's training
partner there's a lot there i get why
you pick him they go and it also sets me
up for a potential counter fight should
that ever happen jake's also trying to
fight conor right
but apparently he's only got two fights
left on his ufc contract either myself
or jake will fight conor mcgregor i
agree eventually like
it's just too much money for you is not
to do that yeah for him as well
same with connor like okay you're not
you're not you're not taking a crazy
[__] risk right like maybe you are
maybe you want i mean if you
if conor mcgregor loses to either jake
or i it that's
that's tough that's a legacy i do think
he would by the way i'm putting this out
there right now and i don't give a [__]
what people think i think you both beat
him i i i think his power translates
from 170 upwards and his fitness is
clearly a problem he fades so fast
and i think especially your gas tank um
and jake's power either or would just be
too much i think so too i think so too
um
but then again i'm [__] delusional i
don't know can we talk about jake's next
fight he's fighting tommy by the looks
of it is that out yet it's pretty much
neil i mean big john fury's confirmed
listen i john fury listen i don't know
what's going on but okay like let's say
hypothetically yes let's say it's
happening how do you how do you feel
because august 6 madison square garden
in my opinion
in jake's last two fights although he
secured the knockout against tyron
woodley and yes he beat tyron both times
i didn't feel like jake's he looked his
best you know like i felt like he was a
little bit sloppier than usual
energy levels didn't look there the zip
in his punches didn't look
i was scared that yeah fight against
tyrant i was scared it was around six
and i'm like i actually think jake's
barely got it thus far like he's gonna
need to do something that he did
something well and that's the thing when
you've got the equalizer in that power
shot he can do that but like
against tommy
if he doesn't land that
what happens tommy tommy has a lot of
skill yeah he does yeah he's quick he's
he's he's slick you know he's got those
little moves that growing up in the fury
family you will pick up yeah and it's
definitely a harder fight in my opinion
sure sure i i i like it i like
everything about it yeah you know
tommy's a good good good lad good young
lad a little bit of an oddball looks
like he
was potentially manufactured
well he was on a reality tv show over
here i don't know if you're aware i'm
saying he's a robot of sorts like he was
put together piece by piece in a factory
oiled and then he looks like a doll in
that regard that's what i'm saying yeah
and he's uh i've seen him on the shelf
at walmart
in a small box
as a figurine
he's not he's um
he's like a barbie a ken doll yeah but
blown up and made sentient actually his
girlfriend is like
that bobby of this
basically the uk oh she's very famous
really molly her name isn't it all the
girls sort of kind of like kim
kardashian and that they sort of model
themselves on like whatever she's
wearing they copy so she's the famous
one and he's sort of the size
he's the b-side he's the b-side of the
relationship
like
he gets most of his fame from his
brother but also from her
and his eyes well he's beautiful his
eyes
his eyes uh
i mean just [__] dude tommy's one of
those guys you look at him in the eyes
and like where am i now i've been
teleported across galaxies absolutely
because they're so just blue and the
abyss is just like wow you just dive in
you know
if we were if we were going to go there
he'd be high on the list fair play room
fair play tomorrow
should we break the fight out a little
what do you think how would you say it
going
so tommy's slick he's going to be in
there for a little while jake's looking
like he's putting a bit of muscle on he
looks like he's he's
he's he's working he thick he's so yeah
working so hard he's working too hard it
looks like they they they're leaning
into what he's good at which is power
yeah it looks like they they're lying
and we've seen tommy get caught with the
right hand in his fights but the fights
were against guys who weren't that good
but what tommy's are going to say is
look look at who jake's fought they're
not on our level either
are you [__] that's not even like
like let's be objective
tommy's opponents were put in against
tommy to lose
like some of them don't have like any
wins
like or just riddled with losses jake is
every time jake fights it's against a
guy who you're like okay this makes
sense this is this is a natural
evolution
based on where your boxing ability is at
he's done this much better than i have i
went i went from ksi an actual [__]
dog
to floyd mayweather yeah you went from
ballroom brawler to
total boxer i didn't get no gib yeah i
get no [__] ben askren yeah
jake's much smarter and way more patient
than i am about boxing
and so what i see happening kind of
based on actually what i just said and
historically what we've seen every
single time tommy will be horizontal
face down knocked out for
some time how do you think people will
deal with that though because this is
the boxer this is finding he's finally
fighting the real boxer and all of that
pressure is going to be on both of them
in a way because tommy has got the
family name and pressure's on tommy yeah
jake lives for this [__] this is the
environment the kid just flourishes he's
used to it dog he's
[__] have no idea what jake's
been through they do not want to know
what it's like to be jake paul
iron proof
the guy is solid
tommy is the younger brother he's got a
lot to prove and like i said there's a
moment in every single fight
where jake paul hits his opponent for
the first time
and they have a moment of like oh [__]
this is this could end very badly i
remember being asked his face when he
got that body shot and it was it was
that moment of oh this is a fight
he's a he was going to be a navy seal
before [__] social media dog like an
actual psychopath a navy seal like the
toughest people on the planet it's jake
and combine the work at the combine the
experience like
you know
under those lights
he thrives because i i felt like with
woodley it it was a bit of a messy uh
fight the last one but but again it was
that knockout punch and you see him just
finding a way yeah to land that shot i
don't know if it's that shot i don't
know if it's that shot he's uh
he's looking
sharp
punches and bunches
combos what about ksi let's go let's go
into him he's fighting alex wassabi by
the looks of it is he looks like that's
the one uh alex
that's crazy cool fight he's coming off
the back of winning against deji so now
he's fighting the bigger brother his
little story arc there um and alex
looked pretty good in that he fit
jabbing and moving you've got jj who
says he's been working a lot and uh is
going to look totally different yeah
he says it every time that's the thing
yeah he didn't look much different in
his fights between your two fights but
this is three years later so there's a
lot that could be done and by the way he
might he definitely might yeah um
my my he's looking physically different
like he's shredded now yeah he's [__] oh
dude he's in good shape he's in good
shape my concern
uh all the pressures on jj though yeah
yeah 100 yeah
this is a gimme fight in the eyes of the
public yeah and it's a war i honestly do
think it's a gimme fight i think i i
just but i've been in the ring with the
kid like he like he just he's a winner
and my only my only it's not even a
concern it's just like i i the one thing
i think a little bit about is when he's
saying like he's gonna look completely
different is like
um
i've just heard that before and i know
there's a dog that comes out of him
when he gets in the ring
[Music]
that sometimes may revert him to the the
windmill
yeah which i don't think will matter
with alex wassabi but alex wassabi
though his style is a lot more well i
don't know who we compare him to but i
guess the way you were originally
fighting jj and jabbing and moving we
can expect although not as physically
built as what you are he's going to do
with that he's going to be on his bike
job run yeah and i hope it works dude
because if one of jj's [__]
cannonballs hits you like that's tough
dude those are those are hard parts
um
yeah
how do you visualize this fight then
i don't know i can't wait i can't wait i
can't wait to see jj in the ring again
you know because he's he's making that
that road to to jake paul now he he
really says that and i've spoken to a
couple of people can't really reveal too
much but it seems like that's the that's
the game plan
um
that puts you in an awkward position
you've got your business partner against
your brother very awkward i wonder
what it would be like being you that
night because that that fight seems it's
a bit too it's a bit like what you said
about conor mcgregor there's just too
much [__] money
for them not to do this as well
and actually jake ksi
because of the hatred because of the
true hatred there
surely we're talking
like one of the biggest fights of the
decade
in terms of money i agree i might uh i
might even try to hop on the uh the
undercard oh
talk about talk about talk about the
biggest fight of the deck decade yeah
that would be the that'd be the craziest
card ever oh yeah if i find the right
dance partner and i'm the co-main event
for jake paul and ksi
i mean that card is logan paul versus
the rock call me an event i can see that
but potentially uh
potentially one of the highest
selling nights ever maybe
i wonder what about gibb
for me yeah jordy what do you think this
is
gibbs good
gib will give you a good fight no he
would jordy
i will i will go spark gibb right now
right from here i will leave this
podcast hungover ghostbar gibber he
won't make it out of two rounds gabe
versus mcbroom the winner
whoever wins that could be a good fight
for you just putting that out there just
putting that out there
i think they both they both beat them
and i think it's such a waste of time i
think they both beat dillon dennis i
know dylan dennis has got something else
but i think in a pure boxing match
they'd both be him just putting that out
there um it's been a good shot today uh
i've i've enjoyed it bro i'm i
i said too much today dude sorry [__]
whatever clip it
put it on take it away blogs
take it
take it away
he's [__] crazy past that
all right that was uh logan paul once
again one of the one of the most regular
guests i've had actually now at this
point on the true johnny podcast we love
him he's a bit hungover we're going to
look after him we'll feed him we'll [__]
him we'll do whatever he needs
you you rushed him [__] me bro you
rested no you [__] me bro yeah thanks
man all right sorry that's it jeffrey
staff probably [__] you so this is a
regular thing no i was considering it
low-key i was sitting across from
jeffrey i was like this dude's
this dude's actually [__] bad as hell
yeah you know
literally literally
do he i mean
what did it feel like to be in a room
with like a james bond villain like that
you know what i'm saying i love him
he's fantastic yeah he's uh
did he tell you who which rappers were
trying to [__] no he didn't i know i
know i should i should have pried yeah
should have cried i also like i want to
be careful with outing [__] like that
i've said it too much bro i gotta go
ahead
that was logan paul on the true johnny
podcast
don't forget to hit that like button
subscribe and we'll see you later cheers